let's look at photos all right well
we're going to Hong Kong first because
our number three top photo today
pro-democracy activists burning a
picture of the city's chief executive as
they hold a banner calling for him to
step down today July 4th is
traditionally a day of protest in Hong
Kong because it's the anniversary of the
city's handover from Britain to China
that was back in nineteen ninety seven
under a one country two systems
agreement is like new protest is just
the time they should be here any protest
but it's gonna be bigger this year
they're predicting 100,000 people
hitting the streets because of course we
have the election later on and you know
there's a big movement towards electing
a pro-democracy candidate as opposed to
approach China candidate number two
NASA's Solar Dynamics Observatory
captured this footage of an eruption on
the side of the Sun Wow look what's a
video no filter just kidding the
eruption ultimately escaped the Sun
growing into a substantial coronal mass
ejection or CME okay it's home you can
explain a giant cloud of solar material
traveling through space the video clip
covers about four hours of the event
eruption is a little bit creepy you
don't want to carry it i'm gonna giving
me goosebumps it's amazing what they've
done last couple years with Cassini and
now we're out by Pluto is well that's
the Sun yeah what willful that's what we
have okay well Stewie my number one
ballerina misty Copeland has been
promoted to the highest rank of the
American Ballet Theatre become the first
african-american female principal dancer
in the company's 75 year history
Copeland who is now 32 joined the
company in april two thousand one she's
been outspoken about her desire to
become the first black woman to be named
a principal dancer at the company I vote
that we take a field trip to go and see
the American though absolutely I mean
it's just great yeah it's great if you'd
shuffle on lake she's going to be here
that's gonna do somebody said she's not
what Nike she's with on your armor yet
your victory for Under Armour is 0
they've been very vocal about promoting
her well they a golf guy as well right
so they've been on a massive streak they
they they're telling small Spieth I've
been very good yeah okay well there it
is